[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt hat jetzt ein weiteres ramadan
bisher ich werde ba klarmachen dass
typisch klassische baklava gibt es
bereits auf meinem kanal es ist schon
ein bisschen länger her aber das rezept
ist immer noch sehr sehr gut
heute mache ich eine abgewandelte
variante und zwar ein lust auf back
bauer ich werde nämlich die füllung von
meinem muss zug nehmen und darauf
backwaren wiso plus ecken krawallos
ecken und muss das alles kombiniert was
ich immer zuerst mache wenn ich baklava
zu bereiten
der zucker sirup der muss nämlich
abkühlen das geheimnis ist nämlich dass
der kalte zuckersirup dann über das
heiße gepäck kommt und dann wird das
backen aber wirklich perfekt ich zeige
euch also mal die zutaten für den
zuckersirup für den zuckersirup verwende
ich 300 milliliter wasser 300 gramm
zucker da nehme ich jetzt mit kokos
blüten zucker eine standard sind 200
gramm honig und ein spritzer
zitronensaft skizziert den chorus blüten
zucker in einem topf zimtstange auch ihr
könnt auch weißen zucker nehmen so wird
es eigentlich traditionell gemacht aber
der cocos blüten zucker der hat seinen
eigenen geschmack von ein bisschen
karamell man sich daher passt es
wahrscheinlich ganz gut wasser dort sei
und auch wohl nicht
und dann darf der zucker sirup erstmal
aufkochen
der honig das ist auch so eine
orientalische sache in der türkei wird
der nicht oft benutzt aber in
griechenland wird er oft benutzt und ich
glaube in marokko auch dann nehmen sie
gerne honig für den sirup jetzt einfach
so lange einkochen lassen ist der see
rot wenn man ihnen herunter tropfen
lässt wie ein faden läuft also nicht so
abgehakt wie jetzt sondern so ein
bisschen dickflüssiger
jetzt ist der sirup soweit ist hat
bereits ausgestellt jetzt lasse ich ihn
wirklich komplett abkühlen nehme nach
etwa fünf minuten die zimtstangen raus
ansonsten wir das aroma zu intensiv die
zimtstange die könnt ihr übrigens
abspiel trocknen lassen und beim
nächsten mal wieder verwenden die hat er
wirklich so viel aroma hier gebe ich
jetzt auch den spritzer zitronensaft
dazu und dann lasse ich jetzt im sirup
komplett abkühlen
für die füllung verwende ich 250 gramm
haselnüsse 30 gramm kakaopulver
ungesüßte einen teelöffel zimt etwas
tonkabohne eine prise salz 50 gramm
cacau nix zum bestreichen brauche ich
mutter und natürlich die backware bled
habe ich nehme jetzt zuerst die mutter
habe ich extra ein sonder im iphone
die darf nämlich auch auf den herd dann
kurz schmelzen lassen dann die nuss
führung
dafür gebe ich jetzt schon mal dem zimt
in eine große schüssel das sagt
dann etwas salz dazu und tonkabohne
tonkabohne ist ein richtig leckeres und
tolles gewürz davon immer nur ganz wenig
nehmen
ansonsten ist es nämlich giftig bei der
muskatnuss dann kommt hier das
kakaopulver mit rein was jetzt hier im
prinzip nur fehlt bei der nuss füllung
für den muster ist ein die mädels und
der zucker aber zuckersirup kommt ja
später drüber daher speichert in zucker
und nehme zusätzlich noch cacau nebst
cacau nix die entstehen aus der
kakaobohne also und ich sind die
bruchstücke davon ist praktisch
umgesetzt und die reinste form sehr
schokolade und das gibt dem ganzen noch
einen schönen krank hier kommen jetzt
noch die nutzer mit dazu
die werde ich jetzt vorher selber malen
und kann diese ein ganz tolles aroma
und ich mache es jetzt gar nicht feinen
sondern lasst ihr noch leicht group für
einen schönen crunch effekt jetzt alles
gut verrühren
ich habe jetzt hier meine glas
auflaufform ihr solltet jetzt auf jeden
fall eine form nehmen die dicht ist und
in der man auch schneiden darf deswegen
den kassa glasform und tätig baklava
blätter die könnt ihr auch gerne selber
machen da habe ich ja bereits ein video
dazu gemacht aber ich finde man muss ja
nicht selber machen also darf man ruhig
auch fertig kaufen die sind nämlich so
schön dünn so bekomme ich sie nicht mit
die ich die form hier drauf ich glaube
so passt ganz gut schneidet das jetzt so
jetzt die frau mit der butter
bestreichen einfach es hier unten und am
rand ich weiß ziemlich butter lastig
aber so sind einfach diese
orientalischen rezepte man macht es auch
so der ramadan der geht ja 30 tage und
dann kommt ja drei tage lang das
ramadanfest da bekommt man wirklich ganz
viel besuch meiner mutter auch und
deswegen macht man da auch desserts die
eben auch lange halten
das heißt man bereite jetzt einmal zu
und dann ist und backen aber wirklich
auch mehrere tage haltbar durch den
zucker sirup und der fed das fett dafür
und das bett ist natürlich auch
geschmacksträger
deswegen sind die ebenso aber ist er
wirklich immer nur ganz kleines
stückchen von daher ist es glaube ich
ganz okay sie kommt jetzt erste schicht
rein dann nämlich gleich zwei drei
blätter
zwischen rhein immer mal wieder ein
bisschen butter dies läge jetzt etwa die
hälfte der blätter rein und zwischen
rhein auch den verschnitt
[Musik]
und bei dem backpulver macht man es
entweder so dass man - maße immer wieder
zwischen rhein schichtet oder eine dicke
schicht macht ich finde beides ganz
lecker hübscher finde ich eine schicht
weil man es dann einfach besser erkennen
kann
und ja meine mama team macht glaube ich
immer so zwischen rhein
das kann man echt so machen sie morgen
dasselbe markt
[Musik]
es kommt hier die nuss füllung rhein mit
einem löffel mit einem loch in der mitte
noch was geht
das klappt wunderbar
schoko backnanger hatte ich selbst auch
machen aber ich glaube das wird ziemlich
lecker jetzt kommen hier einfach noch
die übrigen teigschichten drauf auch mit
der butter dazwischen schön alles
abdecken
[Musik]
jetzt einfach die restliche butter
einmal komplett auf die oberfläche geben
und dann wird es jetzt gleich
geschnitten bevor es gebacken wird nach
dem backen ist es nämlich zu knusprig
und ich schneide jetzt gleich in
dreiecke also erstmal rechtecke
schneiden und dann dreieck
[Musik]
beim schneiden einfach immer nur darauf
achten nicht segen und auch kein sehr
games oder ein schönes glattes und
wirklich nur nach unten schneiden also
einmal durch hacken sozusagen denn wenn
man sagt dann verschieben sich oben die
blätter und dann geht eben diese schöne
optik kaputt da wirklich
jetzt war ich hier noch ein bisschen
rest mutter die kommt hier noch
obendrauf
und dann kommt in den backofen und darf
richtig knusprig gebacken werden aber
wie gesagt wir sicherstellen dass der
zucker sirup schon richtig gut abgekühlt
ist
jetzt ist das backpulver gebacken und
ich hole es sofort raus das klingt das
nicht gut
guckt mal so eine schöne farbe und jetzt
den abgekühlten sirup ganz vorsichtig
darüber fließen lassen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber mir
läuft das wasser im mund zusammen schön
überall verteilen so ein bisschen sehr
ruppig jetzt auf zum servieren glaube
jetzt ist alles schön gedeckt und jetzt
lasse ich das war ein bis zwei stunden
stehen damit der sirup schön einziehen
kann in diese einzelnen teigschichten
und dann können wir schon probieren wenn
ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr das vak war
vor dem servieren noch mit schokolade
übergießen dafür habe ich einfach 50
gramm zar peter kuvertüre gehackt zwei
drittel davon über dem warmen wasserbad
erwärmt und dann kommt da ein halber
teelöffel kokosfett dazu ihr könnt es
dann vom herd herunternehmen dann das
restliche drittel ein rührt und schon
ist die kuvertüre temperiert also heute
darf muss es probieren
ich habe einfach im büro noch gesagt
schokolade und dann statt der marcel
schon da mit mikrofon
hast du schon mal baklava gegessen nein
ich kann es noch nicht mal buchstabieren
aber ich war ist das wenn ich von dir
schokolade ersten tag dann freue ich
mich drauf weil deine ist nie zu süß du
bist nicht allein
der ton kann es auch nicht buchstabieren
nicht mit c
das heißt nicht dass laura baklava um
mal kurz im tor zu dissen so ja also
packte weiß normalerweise immer mit
pistazien oder walnüssen und ich habe
mir immer gedacht mach einfach meine
musik bzw venus topbildung rein und ich
finde das sieht schon ziemlich cool du
kriegst jetzt ist aus der mitte da komme
ich da mache ich hatte darauf ihr müsst
wissen bei marcel kann es nie zu wenig
schokolade sein
stimmt das kann die genug sein kann
meine ich doch
ich habe es gerade so mit der sprache
heraus dass bei google docs
deswegen ist schon deswegen probiere ich
wollte er ist das denn so teuer deswegen
sorgt dann probier mal und wenn man
möchte kann man noch vom sirup dazu
geben aber ich glaube dass das klappt
schon so richtig erfasst die süße reicht
schon
ich glaube man ist sogar da alles mit
der hand weil zahl steckt aber egal das
ist schlecht was er von diesem jahr aber
das steht ja zum glück gerne hinter der
kamera nicht davor zu entwickeln was
schmeckt das schmeckt familie aber
trotzdem 9
das mit den nutzern das kommt über von
becker bekam vor start-ziel und
erfüllung schmeckt das längst fremd
essen beim bäcker ich habe nur becker
gehört oder da habe ich nicht mehr
zugehört wir müssen die illusion
aufrechterhalten dass sie von morgens
bis abends nur bei dir ist schneidet das
video und schmeckt also schön süß aber
mich zu süß ok deswegen habe ich auch
nicht den ganzen see rupp draufgehen ich
bin da muss jeder selber noch
entscheiden ob noch süßer oder weniger
fließen
ja aber ich finds ja cool ich habe auch
gehört wie schön geknackt und das ist
eben das geheimnis heißes gepäck kalter
sirup und dann klappt es auch das ist
wirklich nicht matschig wird sondern
schön knusprig und trotzdem saftig ja
ich probiere jetzt auch gleich ein stück
ich freue mich schon darauf vor allem
finde ich muss echt sagen die farbe
gehen ja normalerweise ist wasser immer
gold gelb und grün mit pistazien erhält
und das ist so ein bisschen dort nicht
richtig schön
falls ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
findet ihr es wie immer auch realismus
blog.de
ich freue mich schon auf euer feedback
bedarf der gerne auch noch was nehmen
bei uns müsst ihr wissen marcel ist
alles auf eine schokolade zu tun aber
auch so mit früchten aufgeführt
guten mehr am anfang habe schon immer
gesagt schokolade aber mittlerweile
woraufhin der frage was ist bekloppt ja
sehr gut das freut nicht also und
schönen ramadan noch wunderschöne zeit
und probiert gerne mal aus bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]
ihr könnt es dann vom herd
herunternehmen das restliche drittel
einfügen ein rohr einführen
ich war schon so richtig hunger